Now, one of the reasons
that apps have often failed
is that they didn't respond
well to their target audience.
All of the audiences you might be
presenting to are going to be well
aware of that fact.
And so, it will be an asset to
you to present evidence from your
user research.
This is the secondary reason
we've been saving all of this.
It allows us to show direct quotations
in text, audio, or video from users.
If you can show that your prototype is
changed in response to user feedback,
you can show that your at least
willing to adapt to the market.
Which is key to having your app be
successful across a more diverse
customer group later on.
What this looks like is largely up to
you, but there are some big no-nos.
Don't focus on all the ways in which
you've gotten it wrong, instead make it
clear that these are ways that your
app has gotten better over time.
Also, try not to show too many
responses from the same user.
It's very easy to focus on the most
eloquent user in each test, but
if you do, you'll be building an app for
that user in particular rather
than your target market generally.
With as many prototyping
iterations as you've been doing,
you should have a wide range of
users who have discussed your app.